[Music]
no more vast barren deserts
because we are going to turn them all
into lush green farmlands
[Music]
how would we go about bringing new life
to hot deserts
how much would this transformation cost
and how could this greenifying
destroy the amazon rainforest
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we could turn deserts into
farmland
with global population growing and a
decrease in healthy land to farm on
now is the time to create new
agricultural technologies
deserts cover one third of all land on
earth
they are the driest ecosystems on the
planet with each receiving less than 25
centimeters of rain every year
so
maybe it's time we turned these barren
lands into something more useful
but could transforming an entire
ecosystem
create an even bigger climate crisis
growing anything in these sands is tough
because some deserts can lose up to 33
times more water than they receive
this happens through the processes of
evaporation and
or as they're known together
evapotranspiration
if you wanted to transform deserts into
farmland you'd need to help the land
retain more water
one method would be a revolutionary way
of mixing very small amounts of clay
into the soil
nanoclay is extremely tiny particles of
clay 500 times smaller than a single
strand of hair
if a layer of this clay surrounded each
particle of sand
it would allow water and nutrients to
stick
in the united arab emirates tests found
that this process reduced
water usage by 47
in just 40 days a barren plot of sand
was able to grow watermelons
and the only two components you need are
water and clay
two things that farmers have been adding
to soil for thousands of years
but it wouldn't be so simple for you
it's not that simple working with thick
clay would be extremely labor intensive
you could also disrupt underground
ecosystems by releasing large amounts of
carbon dioxide or even creating a
waterproof seal over the surface
if you added this liquid nano clay into
water irrigation systems like sprinklers
then it could make its way down to the
roots
if successful the desert sands would now
retain more water
from that the entire desert could be
transformed into high-yield healthy soil
but here's the thing
you'd need a lot of clay
and even more water
if you aimed to terraform all deserts on
earth well that would be about 6.7
quadrillion liters of water
that's nearly half of the water volume
of lake superior the largest of north
america's great lakes
and could your budget handle a bill for
336 trillion dollars
well that's what spraying every single
desert would cost
that's four times the gross domestic
product of the world
oh and did i mention that you'd have to
repeat this every five years
on a positive note you'd now be able to
grow a lot more food and transform life
on farms and villages located around
deserts
no more sand or dust storms shutting
down roads and railways
on a bad note we might just lose the
entire amazon rainforest
let me explain
the amazon acts as a carbon sink
it absorbs carbon dioxide and by doing
so it helps fight off climate change
it also releases much needed oxygen
now how is the amazon connected to
greenifying deserts
well the sand from the largest hot
desert on earth the sahara gets picked
up by winds and crosses the atlantic
ocean all the way to south america
on its way to the amazon the dust
particles pick up moisture
then they fall over the amazon in the
form of rain
and that sand and water combo also works
as a fertilizer
turning deserts green would disturb this
fertilization process to the point we
could lose the amazon rainforest forever
this would be bad news for the climate
thanks to the disruption of the earth's
natural balance
all the plants we'd grow on the newly
terraformed land
might not be enough to prevent the
crisis
not just in the amazon but across the
entire planet
liquid nano clay is just one idea to
help bring sustainable agricultural
growth to the planet's most extreme
environments
but every step forward in one location
can come at a cost to somewhere else
unless we figured out how we could
completely control the climate
but
that's a story
for another
what if